In Android Studio 2.2
We have improved the Visual Layout Editor
Includes built-in support for ConstraintLayout
ConstraintLayout is a good new way
Used to define complex layouts
Without nested view hierarchies
Thanks to this flexible restraint system
You can download it in the Support Repository
Can be used in API level 9
To install it in Android Studio, please open the SDK Manager.
Please click on Android's ConstraintLayout
And the SolverintLayout of Solver
In the SDK toolbar
To use it in your project, please add a variable
And build a gradle
Now create a new layout file using ConstraintLayout
As root view
Please note that in Android Studio 2.2
Layout Editor has some new features
Such as blueprint mode
You can use it with the design view
On the right hand side of the screen
You can see the redesigned view detector
You can use common view properties
And switching between full lists
The detector also includes ConstraintLayout
Unique layout property editor I will show you later
First let's take an image view
Drag from the palette to the blueprint
You can see every view in the ConstraintLayout
There are four empty keys on the side -- top right, bottom left
a view inherited from a text view
There are also baseline controls
Location views are related to each other
You can click and control the same type
Transfer from one place to another
Here I put the text view in the layout
Align it with the right end of the image view
By setting the limit box on the left
I also align these views vertically
By adding a limit box at the top
The distance of these views is still too close
You can adjust the margins by moving the limit box in the design preview.
Or I can use the property window on the right
This looks better.
The rest to be done
Is to place our view in the main limit box
By launching the Show Constraint Settings in the toolbar
I can see it now
No limit box points to the edge of the layout
My two views have moved
Zero position at runtime
Associate the top and left controls of the main margin
I can set how I want to
Put the view in the limit box
If I want to center a view
Instead of being placed at the left or right end of the screen
I can create a new text view and center it horizontally
By associating both sides with the main margin
You can see the two sides of this view now
Have a limit box
Because ConstraintLayout cannot satisfy both limit boxes at the same time
The view is centered
If you look at the properties window now
You can see a slider called Horizontal Bias
Change the percentage value by the slider
I can influence the strength and weight of each limit box.
This can move the view slightly to the left or right
You can also change the width and height of the view.
Through three modes -- the fixed size of the package content
And meet the limit box
You should not use the main margin in ConstraintLayout
Instead, use the Compliance box.
This means that the view can
Make the most of space
Still meet the limit
To remove restrictions
Click on the small box in the properties window
Or click on the control in the design view
You can click here to remove all the restriction boxes in a view.
Or remove all restriction boxes
And layout by using the buttons in the toolbar
We are constantly improving runtime performance
And the function of the editor
To make sure you have the latest version of the SDK Manager
And your build file
Please check out our code lab
And articles on "Medium" to learn more about the advanced case of ConstraintLayout
Thank you for watching.
If you want to learn more about Android Studio
And Android-developed content
Please click here for the video